do you think most of us idolize actors
and respect them
are they like royalty in the US I think
so I think you get more of that from
more of the old-school I think that you
get less of that now and I think that
they're I think you're seeing now a
dynamic shift and I think we're gonna
see more of a dynamic shift in
television I actually think that we're
going to hopefully go back to the old
you know having movie stars I really do
Clark Gable yeah yeah and less vulgarity
and stuff even though we yeah there's
one way on telling a story but then
there's the other way of you know doing
vulgar things outside of your
storytelling world Oh true do and I mean
that's what I'm getting at I mean I
think that I understand that I think
that there's gonna I think that there's
a dynamic shift happening and I see that
and my daughter's generation so in the
20 year olds I'm starting to see more of
that of a change we used to be something
called standards and practices and we've
lost them more and I think that I
Department think that it's slowly coming
back to I think that we're just seeing
the break of that now that way was just
starting yeah sorry no I think that's
just so chivalry is was sleeping perhaps
chivalry is not dead
mm-hmm who was sleeping
it's when Clark Gable was Clark Gable
and Jimmy Stewart was Jimmy Stewart and
John Wayne was John Wayne it was hard to
get your your face in a box or on a
screen impossible I mean other than
slides at home or maybe super 8 or
16-millimeter films that Uncle Charlie
took at the birthday party you couldn't
get there who was it was technologically
impossible for you to get there you know
now some hamster does a backflip out of
his bowl which we watched the other day
I'm on YouTube sitting there just like
oh look at the hamster doing a backflip
out of the bowl now all you have to be
as a hamster that does a backflip out of
a bowl so I think that has eroded the
whole notion of celebrity I think the
reality TV has eroded the notion of
celebrity I think that no one will ever
have any idea if Paris Hilton has any
talent and for a long time nobody cared
she may she may be amazing at something
she may be Lady gaga in front of a piano
I have no idea and no one will know
because she became famous for she became
a celebrity for being a celebrity
somehow already good that chef well I
don't I hope it changes but I maybe
what'll happen is that because you can
get a camera like this and because you
can edit it on your laptop like that one
over there and make something worthy of
being viewed by a populace maybe what
will happen is what happened and I see a
lot of parallels with the music industry
that the music industry became after the
labels went away when GarageBand
happened to your computer and and
Napster happened to publishing and
mechanical royalties when that basically
destroyed a business overnight
what emerged from that was the
singer-songwriter which had been around
Kris Kristofferson was around Hanks
senior was around mean the the people
were around before but that that kind of
came up because those are people who
can't not do it
right so now what we have are people
hopefully like us who are saying well
wait a minute we we have to make a movie
we have got to it's it's July we have
made a movie yet we got we have to make
this movie which one I don't know who's
available let's make a movie so
hopefully what will come out of this
whole cacophony of celebrity hamsters
doing backflips out of bowls will be the
real storytellers that have partnered
with the real technicians that can get
those stories in front of a population
otherwise I think it's going to be more
hamsters and bowls and more talent free
people making $100,000 to show it up at
a nightclub that's going to go away in
six months anyway I mean it's a very
strange time yeah but I think that's
where the opportunity is do you know I
think so yeah for the real the real the
real artists I really want to go correct
and take the risk you have to be the
risk-taker too right and that cannot be
about making the money that's right you
have to take the risk
most most artists were dead long before
anybody knew they were alive
Rembrandt Knight Picasso absolutely they
were they were moderately successful
until all of a sudden you can get those
anymore right well that's more of it
isn't it no we had this conversation the
other day that's just me morbid maybe I
should kill you first death by your own
hand no it has to be by my own hands
I'll let you know
thank you yeah
you